you won't believe this simple trick that
Mr Beast uses for his epic YouTube
thumbnails Mr Beast recently conducted a
little experiment about YouTube
thumbnails showcasing that thumbnails
with his mouth closed perform way better
in terms of viewer watch times this
small but crucial change in thumbnail
design has led to no less than 12 new
videos of Mr Beast with his mouth closed
on the thumbnail he believes it's a game
changer especially when compared with
his older videos it all started when
YouTube announced they were working on a
feature called AB test to determine the
best thumbnails Mr Beast was one of the
chosen creators for the beta testing and
the results speak for themselves with Mr
Beast leading the way we can expect more
creators to follow suit and switch to
Clos mouth thumbnails because